hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to if
you're like me you discover the story of
Mozart through the movie Amadeus not
true not true the movie is entirely not
true have you liked me you always
encounter someone who says this instead
of trying to get all your information
from movies why don't you just try
knowing everything like I do oh it seems
like if you even bring up that you enjoy
the film somebody has to talk about the
historical inaccuracy to its credit
Amadeus never claims to be a true story
based on the play Amadeus looks at the
life of Wolfgang Mozart from the point
of view of another composer named
Antonio Salieri
he claims he killed Mozart because he
was jealous that such talent had fallen
on what appeared to be a giggling dirty
delinquent this is one of those movies
everybody can get behind it's visually
interesting yet dramatic intrigue
hilarious comedy and introduce people to
a part of music history that was
phenomenally fascinating most people
when they hear Mozart think his life is
going to be one of just looking fancy
and keeping up appearances
but many people myself included we're
enjoyably surprised to find out how
weird funny brilliant
immature and even kind of downright
insane the prison could be and none of
it is true so you see you actually know
nothing about Mozart why don't you just
swipe left that's what you see
everywhere where I pictures just swiping
I thought the movie got me so into the
life of Mozart I decided to do a little
research to see how accurate it actually
was but this way to do this is to go for
the common complaints that people swear
must have been made up for the movie
scholars and musicians bristled at its
depiction of the composer as a silly
overgrown child with a hyena cackle and
it probably goes without saying but
there are spoilers in this if you
haven't seen it yet check it out it said
by many including myself to be one of
the finest movies ever made with that
said let's start on a topic so common
that even the Simpsons addressed it
Mozart was a lazy idiot at the end of
the very funny spoof The Simpsons did at
the film
Lisa points out that the movie has a lot
of historical inaccuracies claiming
Mozart worked very hard on his music and
Salieri was a respected composer
they just make him look like a buffoon
like frilly music just came to him and
he put no effort into it whatsoever
but many people are just going by the
impression it made not what the film was
actually saying it is documented that
Mozart had a very immature even dirty
sense of humor
he loved fart jokes and sex jokes and he
was boastful and bad with money
this kind of attitude would certainly
give the impression that he didn't know
what he was doing and that he was just a
party out like how many saw him in the
movie but the film does explain that he
works all the time it doesn't just come
to him out of nowhere he's just
constantly thinking of music 24/7 and is
planning it out in his mind does he work
at all oh yes sir I don't mean that he's
lazy cuz he's not at all he works all
day long he just sits there writing and
writing this makes a lot of sense when
you see how much his father hammered
music into his brain as a child but yes
they acknowledge that the music took
time and effort and in response to the
other comment that Salieri was a
respected composer the movie never said
he wasn't in the opening we see more
people remember Mozart's music rather
than his but it's shown clearly that not
only was Sally Aires work adored in his
day but many loved it even more than
Mozart's as Mozart's work seemed too
different and knew at the time it is the
best opera yet written my friend you do
honor to Vienna Anthony which brings us
to the next questionable subject de
fellow composers including Salieri
actually hate Mozart Mozart often wrote
that he felt the other composers were
blocking him trying to stand in the way
of his work reaching even greater
success and yes the Emperor did famously
say that his music had too many notes
which is like saying a book has too many
letters there are simply too many notes
that's all just cut a few when it'll be
perfect he was never given a position in
the Emperor's court one of the reasons
being he didn't just write his music for
the musical elite he wrote it so that
the ever man could appreciate it as well
there were also so many the one to see
Mozart as a one-trick pony or a dancing
monkey seeing how his fame started when
he was just a little kid so naturally
there were critics that said he was the
equivalent of
what we would call a fading child star
still he was popular for the most part
and able to calm down his wild attitude
when he needed to so while this is more
speculation and it's impossible to
figure out how far it went it's still
not without plausible possibility ah but
what about the masked man that
commissioned the Requiem from him the
person who was trying to steal the work
for himself clearly that his work of
Hollywood well I'm that you're correct
you see he didn't wear a mask what yeah
the part you'd swear was out of a lame
Hollywood thriller actually contains a
lot of truth a composer named couch
franz von wall sig anonymously
commissioned Mozart to compose a requiem
for his late wife the count had a
history for taking compositions from
famous composers and passing it off as
his own as he was an incredible pianist
but not the best composer so it's
incredibly likely he was going to do the
same with Mozart's work he used servants
and messengers to communicate with the
ill Mozart and as shown in the movie he
died in the middle of writing it was
then handed off to other composers to
try and complete it so that his wife
could still collect the money and pay
off a lot of the dead that her husband
accumulated so while it wasn't Salieri
as it said in the movie it was still
someone who had quite a devious plan
proving once again truth really can be
stranger than fiction yes yes but let's
not tap dance around the biggest
inaccuracy the one that the whole film
is centred around
Salieri did not claim he killed Mozart
hmm oh come on now are we conspiracy
theorists okay oh not at all it's
incredibly unlikely the Salieri did
anything that he said he did in the
movie but he did claim that he killed
Mozart in his later years Salieri just
like in the film tried to kill himself
and confess that he was the one
responsible for Mozart's death and since
there weren't really doctors of mental
health back then they called a priest
who would listen to him explain how he
finished him off now historians have
dismissed this as mad ravings of a
person whose sanity has clearly
deteriorated but this is where the film
gets very clever who's telling the story
Salieri
that means that the whole thing could be
told under the guy
is that he believes what he's talking
about really happen if you look at it
that way even to the point where he
convinces the priests that what he's
saying is true the story suddenly takes
on a much more interesting angle Mozart
even near the end of his life swears
he's been poisoned and often says days
writing the Requiem more for himself but
in terms of Salieri doing it this is the
part that's clearly historical fiction
this is where we enter Oliver Stone's
JFK or The Da Vinci Code
it's a fantasy told in a world of fact
but what makes this so clever is that
you can just say everything around
Salieri is mostly fiction while
everything around Mozart is mostly
accurate he worked hard on his music
like the movie said he could be immature
like the movie said he was a debtor a
drinker a boaster but also one of the
most unbelievable talents the world has
ever known so when somebody says on the
dais is totally nonsense you can say
that the majority of it is true except
for the Salieri parts those parts are
based on the theories and stories that
spread over the years deceitful stories
so crazy and unbelievable based off of a
life so crazy and unbelievable that it's
hard to know where one ends and the
other begins that's the genius of the
movie it blends fiction and reality so
well that even years later people still
confuse what really happened and what
didn't
it's just easy to label it as one thing
and dismiss people who see value in its
historical relevance but the life of
Mozart can't be labeled as one thing
it's too strange for that this movie did
its homework in getting a lot of the
history in a correct and intentionally
incorporated fiction to enhance a life
that is very hard to get a grasp on it's
funny when you see how many people boast
about how many things the movie got
quote-unquote wrong as if the creators
didn't know what they were doing very
similar to how the composers in the
movie assume Mozart didn't know what he
was doing because he was too strange and
new in fact with all the people talking
about the inaccuracies even though they
got a lot of those inaccuracies wrong
you could argue that they're the ones
who are misinformed follow phrases never
been
you know there are still things left
unknown about Mozart and his work and
even what we do know is subject to some
speculation so nobody will ever get the
full story but only a life as strange as
this could blend truth and fiction
honesty and deceit in such a perfect way
Mozart's life never could and never
should be told straightforward
it's a maddening spin that has to be
experienced and challenge you exactly
like his music does it's bizarre yet
humanizing dark yet bright funny yet
serious something to have on in the
background or listen to by some of the
greatest musicians of our time the film
is a masterwork that deserves to be
honored as much as Mozart himself is and
if anybody tells you you shouldn't enjoy
because of its inaccuracies you can tell
them that your reason for liking it
simply has too many notes for them to
understand well that it is I'm a
nostalgia critic I remember it so you
don't have to coming next week it's the
CGI monstrosity Alvin and the Chipmunks
it's time to take a look at the squeak
list but you can see it now under
vessel's ad free early access just three
dollars a month to see tons of people's
videos early as well as a bunch of other
extra features check it out and get the
early scoop
you